that's another reason why they have
never become this very sophisticated
criminal organization because they're
really bad criminals
you know i mean it comes down to that
and like and if you are managing a very
sophisticated criminal organization
why would you align yourself with them
they're totally visible they fall on the
radar of law enforcement
non-stop they're all tattooed up and
they're really bad at what they do and
there's so many possible
leaks of information and it just doesn't
make sense on so many levels to align
yourself with them
how do you describe what you do for work
i would say i find
human stories about
organized crime and corruption mostly
in the americas where i live
and i try and tell those human stories
to illustrate
institutional or systematic problems
that we
face as societies as countries
and you know for me the most exciting
thing
is getting to and telling those human
stories that's
that's the part that gets me up in the
morning and that's what i spend most of
my time doing so a lot of it is kind of
finding these people getting them to
talk to you and then reconstructing
their stories hopefully in the most
accurate way possible
we as humans are incredibly complex uh
but
we are we're gray there's no black and
white
so that's what i aim to tell is that
gray area i love that gray area
that's where the interesting stuff is
yes absolutely so i'm a specialist
in the gray area i get that
you've been focused on ms-13 for quite a
while now what is ms-13
ms-13 is a gang that was born
really from refugees
that were fleeing a civil conflict in el
salvador
and other parts of central america
eventually in the 1980s and they landed
in
spaces like los angeles in the deep
heart of los
angeles and found themselves in the
midst of
hundreds of street gangs and they formed
one of their own
initially it's a gang that is
grouped together or at least their their
their their sort of common bond
was initially heavy metal music of all
things
um so that's i guess innocent enough and
um
that evolved evolved for a lot of
reasons
perhaps most of all because of the
environment in which they were
living and it became this international
or
transnational gang over the last
40 years it is an incredibly
notorious gang even if it's not the most
violent mostly because of these very
gruesome ways in which they go after
and often kill their rivals or perceived
rivals they use
blunt instruments like machetes knives
those sorts of things
and they kill in groups so they act as a
group
and they often kill in numbers so you
know
three to four victims what would be
considered sort of a massacre in
international standards
you know those sorts of things and very
often in public
so they have this you know fearsome
reputation but they're really kind of uh
uh they're a haphazard
loosely knit network they're grouped
under this umbrella the ms-13 but
they're
they're linked they're they're they're
more linked more closely connected to
what what are called clicks or their
sort of personal cells
where they grow up so it's a very you
know while it's international
most of their activities are very much
local
so that's that's where it comes from and
that the fascination around them comes
from
just mostly i would say this gruesome
way in which they go after their rivals
or perceived rivals
do they have a leader they have leaders
each of the cliques that i mentioned has
a leader
underneath or i say i should say above
the clicks they have are what are called
programs and those group a number of
clicks
and there are probably in the range of
35 or 40 programs
and this is in a half dozen countries
now
mostly in the americas but there are
they are popping up now in europe
and then above them they have leadership
um kinds of boards of directors really
that work that work kind of
geographically speaking so you have a
board of directors
or what they call a mesa or a table of
directors
in la you have another one which is
probably the most powerful one
in el salvador um it's known as the
the ramfla they call it the ramples
torica which means
quite literally the translation would be
historical wheel
rampla wheel it goes back to their
origins in la where there is a
fascination with cars
right and you'll think of the very
cliched cars
bouncing up and down yeah that's the ram
fly right let's get that ramp
right so they take that and it's
transformed in sort of
in sort of the it's it's referred to as
the wheel
or the leadership circle and historical
is
historical so this is the traditional
leadership that's probably the most
powerful
um board of directors that the ms-13 has
but no one part of the gang has complete
control
over the other parts of the gang um and
that's the thing that's very hard
for people to wrap their heads around
there isn't like one single
el chapo there's no no there's no one
single leader moving these guys around
like
chess pieces um you know of you know
very common misperception about what
what the gang is it's very loosely knit
network
and they are most mostly loyal
to their clicks and their click leaders
in particular the person who
administered
they're beating in so they have rituals
to enter into the gang
and one of them is this sort of beat in
ceremony that lasts
well they say 13 seconds but that's a
long 13 seconds that they're counting
away
while a bunch of guys are beating up
this guy who's going to be initiated or
who is being initiated
and their loyalty then is to the person
who administered that
very often so it's it's it's a very
very sort of difficult thing again to
wrap our hands around
what's it got to do with the mexican
mafia there's affiliations there as well
isn't there
the mexican mafia is this sort of prison
gang
um is a prison prison-based
gang mostly run out of southern
california state prisons
and what they understood
as a kind of gang very early on
was that if they controlled the prison
systems
in particular the the the latinos
inside the prison system they could set
up and extend their network
beyond the prison walls themselves
so beginning really going back to the
1950s and 1960s they established
a firm control over the latinos
inside the u.s prison system why is that
important well in the united
states the prisons are really divided
along
racial lines and so it's basically
brown versus black versus white in the
in the crudest sense
of of understanding how it works there
and to the mexican mafia which
i know that you've spoken about in other
shows of yours
you know was able to sort of corral all
the latinos
underneath an umbrella an umbrella group
they call the surenos
and at a certain point they not only
sort of
you know would take people who came in
but they began to force
all of the southern california latino
gangs
to become part of that umbrella group
the surenos
and that was the case with the ms-13
they were essentially
forced into this umbrella group the
surenos
so they're part of this mexican mafia
umbrella group which gives the mexican
mafia
this sort of control and leverage over
the comings and goings of
all of these street gangs operating in
southern california and beyond
and they can use these networks for
themselves
so they can make money and they do make
loads of money as you well know the
the mexican mafia is a very you know
they're sort of a member of the mexican
mafia it's anywhere between 100 and 130
members
so very small compared to these street
gangs like the ms-13 that have
thousands and thousands of members what
do they care right
this is just contract labor for them um
so they're able to in essence sort of
extend
their criminal networks via these gangs
like the ms-13
i suppose if you're in jail and the
choices between
striking out on your own or finding a
partnership with
your people if the mexican mafia is if
it's a choice between those two why
would you try and splinter off on your
own the whites aren't going to have you
the blacks aren't going to have you
presumably
so you've got to go with those people
going back to el salvador
is it right that there's about a
murderer minute in el salvador and it's
got a population that's less than london
not currently it has gone down
considerably since your murder minute
statistic probably came out um it
was there was a time in which it hovered
around
100 murders per 100 000
which would far surpass whatever
london's is which i would imagine is
maybe even one or below that per 100
000. so you know 100 ti at any point it
was a hundred times
more you're more likely to be murdered
in
el salvador than you were in london so
yes in that regard it has gone down
considerably and there is a lot of
debate about why it's gone down
and one of the theories around why it's
gone down
is because of an alleged pact between
the current government
and mostly in this case because the
ms-13 isn't the only gang there but
mostly the ms-13 because it is the most
powerful gang
in el salvador and what does this pact
entail it entails
a a a trade-off where
the gang says we're we're going to lower
homicides
at least we're going to make it so you
don't find nearly as many bodies
so disappearances forced disappearances
by the way are going way up
and the murder rate goes down this is
politically advantageous because
we on the outside what do we do we use
murder rate as a proxy for
evaluating how a country is doing on
security in security matters
you know it's probably not a fair proxy
but that's the proxy we use
so that goes down great so you know
foreign direct investment and all the
other things that come along you know
accolades and look at you
you're solving the gang problem all of
that comes with it
right and in return what does the
government do it gives them
you know sort of special visiting rights
and privileges inside of prisons
you know to their loved ones and others
including
reported by some not necessarily by us
and i
work i should say i work for insight
crime which is a think tank that covers
these matters
you know you know it includes this sort
of
you know maybe quid pro quos of of
trading off certain things
inside the prisons including having
meetings or brokering meetings of guys
from the outside
on the inside so they can continue to do
business
um you know visitation rights for family
members as you know that is super
important
um you know and then also their ability
to control
the administration of special assistants
and especially during this time of kovid
in the neighborhoods that they control
so in other words you have a government
program that is providing special
assistance to people in need
during the pandemic who administers that
who hands out that assistance what we
understand is that
gang members begin to control that
assistance so what does that give them
that gives them a huge amount of capital
and clout in those communities where
they operate
so you can see how this quid pro quo
operates you know i guess the last thing
in
an arguably super important thing
especially from the political
perspective
is that they open up the door for
political parties that the principal
political party run by the president
to campaign in their in their areas
under their control
and they prohibit the other campaigns
from going in their areas under their
control so
how do you campaign you know how do you
do a political campaign
this worked very much in the favor of
the government who ended up
winning the midterm elections and now
controls congress by a healthy margin
and it looks as if they might even
change the constitution so the president
can stay
on for years and years
so you can see how this can have real
real
effects wow i can't believe
that what they gave the government was
will make the bodies disappear the kit
we can't we can't
promise anything about the murders but
the bodies there'll be fewer bodies
around and that's
that's ended up yeah it really does feel
like they've got their fingers into
absolutely everything what is it that
they want do they have a mission
obviously when you look back to kind of
the classic the the
mexican cartels and stuff like that
there was this
vision of riches and drugs and kind of
conquering
and controlling territory what's the
equivalent for ms-13 what's their goal
yeah they they don't have a goal i mean
that they are
very much uh for the most part up until
now and we're talking about sort of a
40-year history where mostly
it has been a rudimentary hand-to-mouth
existence
it is about the here and now about sort
of
living the day and part of that and this
is what i've learned
now 10 years you know investigating this
and talking to gang members
is is the social aspect i think we
really downplay the social
part of of the gang we put the criminal
aspect first we talk about them as a
cartel
or they have this money-making machine
as it relates to extortion
or maybe they're involved in human
smuggling or prostitution rings
or whatever the case may be we put the
sort of cart before the horse
i think in that we put the criminal
economy in front
and we say this is what drives them no i
don't think so
i think what drives them is their social
cohesion
and and their bonds with one another and
their relationship with one another
they they are not a rich organization
this
isn't a a huge money-making operation
now there are elements of the gang that
are showing signs
of changing this in terms of
getting involved in in increasingly
sophisticated drug trafficking
activities
but these are very small elements within
uh you know the we're talking about the
ms-13 umbrella
uh we're talking about anywhere between
50 000 and 100
000 members across you know six
different countries and we're
talking about you know just a few dozen
getting involved in these more
sophisticated activities because most of
the others
while they may be making a lot of money
in for example extortion
and they are that's parceled out through
many many many hands through all of
these thousands of hands
and their family members you know and
others who they have to pay off along
the way in order to
do these criminal activities so
we can talk about them making you know
in the millions of dollars but that is
spread out among many hands and to be
honest
you know again going back to the most
important point for me is
they are a social organization first you
know
maybe we want to call them antisocial in
many respects but they're social
it's a community we don't want to think
of it that way but it is a community
first
a social community first a criminal
organization second
to the point where in our investigations
what we found and what i found in my own
investigations
um are that these
these um members who become
very good very entrepreneurial in what
they're doing for example in drug
trafficking
they are literally pushed aside they're
pushed out of the organization
and they don't even use the organization
in many respects to do these
sophisticated criminal activities
because they know that that's
not what the organization is built for
that's not what the ms-13 is built for
um so it is it's it's very hard for us
to wrap our heads around this because
at and this is where i started as well i
started by looking at it as a criminal
organization i was
looking at it this what are their
criminal activities that's what
drives them right no that's not what
drives them
that's interesting i wonder whether the
classic
south american drug
cartel mafia style approach that's kind
of
embedded in the back of our brains i
wonder whether that's washing them and
we always look okay so what's the
commercial enterprise here
what's the game that they're playing are
they are they running rackets like the
new york
mafia or they are they in the concrete
game are they in the drug game are they
in the people trafficking game
that's the interesting thing about ms-13
i think you call them this this
hand-to-mouth organization
that for whatever better word they don't
sound tremendously sophisticated
um like a a poorly funded
poorly organized version of other
cartels that have come before them
i don't know how i feel about that i
wonder whether it
it makes it feel a little bit more
desperate
in a way it makes it feel less bourgeois
and kind of like they had a choice
it certainly feels like if they're doing
this because they need the social
cohesion
that it's there for a the purpose feels
more human
but that also makes the killing and the
violence seem more wanton
does that make sense absolutely and
these are the
this that's that's sort of a central
paradox in all this you you really hit a
central paradox with the ms-13 is that
they are they are victims in a certain
way and they
and they are victimizers you know they
they embody
both of these things yeah constantly
yeah yeah yeah
we can pick out the victim's side and we
can pick out the victimizing side and we
can highlight whichever one we want
at the time that most suits us they
do commit horrendous acts of violence
my argument would be that those
horrendous acts of violence
are part of the way in which they create
this group cohesion
they're not they're not even part of
what they're doing
as uh as a means of establishing control
over a criminal almost purposeless
you think of it as purposeless in the
sense of of your
rational economic mind but it's totally
totally purposeful when you think about
it in your social
cohesion binding them together as a
group shed shared sacrifice
illustrating my commitment and shared
sacrifice
because that's what i'm about that's the
most important element
so there if you look at the cases
against them the cases against them
are all cases of assault and murder
and you know there are some cases of
sophisticated
activities you know sophisticated
meaning the most sophisticated they get
are and this just came up in an
indictment uh
about six months ago in the united
states was moving
100 i believe it was
i want to say a hundred tons of
marijuana that was the
the most not 100 tons sorry 100 pounds
of marijuana
um you know this is this is like really
low level stuff when you're thinking
about
the grand scheme of cartels yeah yeah
it's not a cartel exactly it's just not
they just don't get there and when they
the guys who do start to get there what
they do is
they liaise with them with the guys like
the mexican mafia
they start to interact with them um
they are trying their best to
get accepted into the mexican mafia the
six or seven cases that uh at inside
crime that we've chronicled over the
years
that illustrate these international drug
trafficking schemes
you know uh com commandeered by
by leaders of the ms-13 they're almost
invariably
um connecting with and working with the
mexican mafia
not with their own gang they need to
outsource
to a more sophisticated business unit
because within their own gang they don't
have any of the people that are of this
sort of commercial entrepreneurial
enterprising mind i don't know whether
that's a i don't know whether that's a
good thing or a bad thing i can't work
that out
i read about um murder rape control
being some sort of tagline what's that
about
i mean there there's a lot of myths
i don't know whether to call this a myth
but you know there's a lot of stories
that i think
in part are promoted um
you know by the gang as
um things that are part and parcel of
the gang
this is this is kind of one of them you
know like i think it's just part of
a gang trying to burnish its reputation
as being
extremely strong and vicious and
ruthless
um because i have never and this is i
have interviewed
dozens of these guys not one of them
has ever spontaneously talked like that
to me as i
spontaneously said oh yeah our our motto
is you know this this and that is not
how it works
so i i sometimes think that these things
got
picked up and then they just become they
kind of take on a life of their own
i think this is probably one of them
yeah um
a little bit of artistic license like
you might use to embellish the
features of a product the features of
their product are their scariness and
their viciousness
and it helps them it helps prosecutors
it helps police departments get more
resources
you know it helps politicians get
elected i mean
it is a win-win-win-win situation with
with these kind of
you know these little teeny myths that
kind of percolate
about about these organizations um you
know i think just one more thing going
back to the the social aspect that i
think we have to keep in mind
is that it it makes them in the long
haul i think it has made them more
resilient
to law enforcement efforts because if
you
are simply thinking that you're going to
take away their criminal economy
and you are going to thus remove their
sort of
core element of being you're sorely
mistaken in fact by throwing them in
jail
you are just reinforcing this social
cohesion
which is what happens over and over and
why they were able to
basically replicate the mexican mafia
style when they move their operations
uh to el salvador and other places in
central america
i suppose they're kind of like bitcoin
they're such a decentralized
structure they don't have one single
operator
structurally in terms of the way that
the hierarchy is ordered and that
earning potential is also done in that
same way there isn't
some great river with tributaries coming
off it that everybody's feeding on
it's all just little rackets here and
there it's
making the bus driver pay there was like
a bus driver's strike or something
because
they were threatening the bus drivers
that they needed to pay them
then there's bus drivers dead in the
street and stuff like this so yeah i
suppose
as being resilient as a gang goes
staying poor is actually quite an easy
way to do that because there isn't
one single income stream that can be
chopped away when it comes to who
they're recruiting who
where are they getting their members who
are they recruiting
i i think they're they're they're
recruiting where
um where gangs recruit you know
youth in the neighborhood
at the schools
yes absolutely they are um
the the members those who become members
um talk about their first interactions
with the gang
you know when they are toddlers um
and because the gang is around right
it's just another element that is
that is around that could be part of
their house it could be part of their
neighborhood could be part of their
school
um and so the gang is there it's sort of
around and in many places these are
the coolest kids i mean they have access
to
the coolest toys you know um
the best music the marijuana you know
it's not too different from what draws
us as youth to any crowd
you know so i don't think it's
necessarily that different in that
respect i think in other respects it can
be very different in the sense that
i may join the gang just to be safe
or think that i am safe from the gang
you know i live in a neighborhood where
the gang is operational
and one of the ways in which to keep my
own self to keep myself safe
is to join them or to collaborate with
them in in some
in some respect or maybe to think that
i'll keep
my myself maybe not safe but maybe my
brother's safe
or my sister and my family and all the
rest you know so
i think there's a lot of different
motivations that go into this
what what i hear what i've heard over
the years talking to gang members
is that in places like el salvador for
instance
they don't have to recruit they have a
pretty
steady line of possible recruits
kind of hovering on the edges what i
think we don't often take into
account in a lot of these spaces both in
el salvador places like el salvador in
the united states
is how much violence is happening inside
the home
and how so many of these guys don't want
to be in their house
and find themselves on the street just a
lot of time on the street
for a lot of reasons but very often
because they have been subjected to
violence in their home and it could be
you know physical violence or it could
be sexual violence so it's a literal
second family then a literal surrogate
family absolutely
and again going back to this social the
social aspect it is definitely their
their surrogate family uh no question
about it and they all talk about it like
that
it's a bit of a cliche but i don't think
it's far from the truth for them
uh in that in that core element that
family allows them
to speak their own language and and in
the book i go through some of this
where you've got a salvadoran migrant
in a largely mexican mexican-american
neighborhood avoiding the way in which
he would normally say the word
you you know just referring to you you
know he would use the word
boss but that immediately identified him
as a salvadoran so he had to switch his
language
until he found the salvadorans who were
embracing that
and who were they they were the ms-13
so you know it we think of we don't
necessarily think of these things but i
think they play a big role
in in drawing these these groups of
people together
into this into this community talk me
through the full
initiation procedure then you've talked
about this 13 seconds thing i've also
heard about
some pretty disturbing stuff that women
are supposed to have to do if they're
going to get in and then there's some
other
steps how does it work quick parentheses
would be that women are no longer
um allowed into the ms-13 sometime in
the early 2000s they made a kind of
election patriarchy bloody patriarchy
again
it is the bloody patriarchy and uh
you know yes there were very as far as
uh female initiates
you know that i and i i spoke to um
uh a few of them one of them is is
chronicled in my book there is this sort
of
you know there's kind of two avenues
you're either sexting where you have to
have
sex with multiple members of the of the
gang the clique in this case
or you're beaten in so you know the ones
that i spoke to
both said that they they had been beaten
into the
gang because if you're sexting then
you're really never a member of the gang
um anyway but in terms of the the way in
which you reach that that stage because
there's really a long
process or there can be a long process
before you reach the
initiation stage where you're beaten in
and that that differs
uh depending upon geography um in places
where you have
a lot of potential recruits like el
salvador that period
at least when i was doing the bulk of my
research a couple of years ago
you know could last a couple of years um
and that included sort of you know
starting you out doing
very basic services you know keeping an
eye out
uh those sorts of things may be starting
to
messenger um things back and forth
you know maybe you're involved then into
you know you can see kind of it's sort
of escalating
maybe you're involved in sort of
collecting uh for
the you know the money from extortion
you know those
sorts of things and it steadily
escalates to the point where
you're you're at a certain point
required to or at least
asked to participate in a murder or two
um you know there were differing stories
about how many murders you had to commit
in order to be
part of the gang there are periods i
would suppose when you have to commit
more murders
rather than less so i don't think it
necessarily is sort of a hard and fast
rule
and it's very much related to again
geography you don't necessarily get that
same rule of having to commit
one or more murders if you are being
ushered into the gang
in a space like the united states which
has five
far higher costs to being a violent gang
than being a violent gang in a space
like el salvador so
there are kind of differing ways in but
it's sort of this sort of
rising scale of of activities till you
reach the point where okay now you're
going to be a member
they'll beat you in but even after that
you have to continue to illustrate
what they call commitment and you do
that very often
by these collective are participating in
these collective
expressions of violence these multiple
members going after other
rivals you know basically and again
not necessarily and very often not even
related to criminal economies
just this illustration of group cohesion
just this illustration of
we are the strongest um so you know it
is it kind of boggles the mind but
that's why
that's another reason why they have
never become this very sophisticated
criminal organization because they're
really bad criminals
you know i mean it comes down to that
and like and if you
are if you are managing a very
sophisticated criminal organization
why would you align yourself with them
they're they're totally visible
they fall on the radar of law
enforcement non-stop
they're all tattooed up i mean you know
and they and they're really bad at what
they do and there's so many possible
leaks of information you know you just
it just doesn't make sense on so many
levels to align yourself with them
and then inside they're just they're
just bad criminals i mean it's just
maybe it comes down to that
yeah maybe what about leaving how hard
is it to leave
i think i think again it varies from
place to place i think it's much harder
to leave
in spaces like like el salvador um
it's a smaller space the circles are
smaller everybody knows each other
and you know it is it's it's difficult
to leave um and then that in that area
which is why you get a lot of them
applying for asylum in the united states
because
they leave and they find they can't
really leave
um and even if they um
sort of go through the process and there
is a process whereby you are
basically supposed to ask for permission
how does that give permission so you you
get old
you have a family you have a job you
have other responsibilities and you can
ask to leave and you give you're given
sort of permission
and you be you become basic what they
call a call
you know you're calmed you're retired
now here's the thing you can be called
out of retirement
if you go through this this way now you
can
you can ask for another way to leave
which is you can say i'm going to join
the evangelical church
and then in that instance if you do
commit yourself
for real to the evangelical church
you cannot be called out or you will
it's very unlikely you'll be called out
of retirement
in that case if you show your commitment
you dedicate yourself
to this other higher cause which by the
way has
a lot of parallels with the gang life
again we don't think of it in that way
but there is a lot of parallels
and then the third way is you run out
you run away that's the third way
you get out run and you say i'm not
turning around and they could be chasing
you your whole life
which is the case i have in that kind of
forms the spine of my book
with norman yeah what's what's the deal
with the church
thing do the gang respect religious
faith
so much that it supersedes their
cohesion as a group
i think that there is a respect for um
religion in the sense that you are
devoted to a higher cause like you are
with the gang so
when you're in the gang you know
everything is about el barrio right this
idea of community
which is sort of their word for
community el barrio the neighborhood
and in the same way they see that
um sort of interestingly in the
evangelical church they
don't have the same appreciation or
relationship with the catholic church
but with the evangelical churches there
obviously many many evangelical
churches and strains
they have this acceptable avenue
of of of escape
um again as long as you dedicate and you
illustrate that you are committed to
that
you know and you don't stray away you
could say i joined the evangelical
church and if they find you drinking and
smoking and
all this stuff you could find yourself
in deep trouble
um so they have this relation
this this this reverence for that
yeah that they don't have for the
catholic church and they allow that
um and yeah we know again just going
back just quickly about the similarities
you know our sense from from like an
inside crime perspective and from a
steve dudley perspective is that there
is a lot of similarities
in the structure of life it's a very
patriarchal system both are very
patriarchal systems
both occupy a huge amount of your time
so you're going to church every night or
you're going to
you know what they call meetings every
night for the gang
you have this commitment again to this
higher higher cause
you know it's about sort of group
cohesion there's a lot of solidarity in
churches
and obviously a lot of solidarity in the
gangs so anyway yeah
all that to say that there's a lot of
parallels i'm not surprised that they're
not getting
much crime don't know much money made
they're too busy they're
constantly at meetings or in church
singing hymns and stuff i'd have
i'd have no time to do anything at all
what's the story can you explain the
story that
norman your character pseudonym
character for a real person in the book
goes through
um where he needs to prove there's a 50
or greater chance that he's going to be
killed or tortured
so he goes to the united states um
running from the gang um he wanted to
wanted to leave oh no they wanted to
make him a boss of some kind
then he said i don't want to do that i'm
going to leave and they said you're not
and he said i am and then he run
yes um so he he's escaping he
he escapes one uh attempt on his life
by the gang and then the and the police
nearly kill him as well so he's got a
lot of enemies and the rival gang the
18th street doesn't exactly like him
either
um so he's got a lot going on and he's
recently
out of jail let's say you know i guess
he's a few years out of jail at that
stage
and huge portions of the gang have been
put in jail
uh leadership and so they have they have
holes in their leadership
outside of jail so they start calling
him up and he ignores their calls
there's only so long you can ignore the
call
of the ramfle historical right which is
basically the
leadership council is calling him up so
he
runs and his family comes in you know
kind of behind him
and his family hands they hand
themselves over to the united states
authorities at the
at the texas border he doesn't have that
option
um he can't because of his gang
affiliation
can't apply for asylum like his family
members can
so he has another avenue that he can use
in order to stay and get what's called
relief from deportation from the united
states
and it's called the convention against
torture it's an international convention
one of the signatories is the united
states and basically
it means that as a signatory
you have the obligation of evaluating
whether or not
a place where you would send somebody
back to deport somebody back to
would be so dangerous um that they would
face
a greater than 50 percent chance of
being tortured and or killed
by the state okay it has to be the state
that would commit that crime
right so in essence the judge is
evaluating whether or not the salvadoran
state
probably pretty specifically the police
in this case the salvadoran police
would find and kill or at least allow
for others to kill perhaps norman in
this case
inside a prison inside the prison system
for example
um or torture him right is there a
greater
than 50 chance that that's going to
happen that's what the judge
is evaluating so that's why the part
about him
you know escaping narrowly escaping
death the hands of the police
is so fundamental um and in that case if
the judge finds that
he is obliged because the united states
is a con
is a signatory to this international
convention
to give him relief as long as that is
the case
so that means that norman even though he
eventually obtains relief
under that convention um you know and he
is a gang member too which
obviously this is the this is the
tension you know you've got
this admitted gang member who is at that
point enemy number one of the trump
administration
applying for relief to stay in the
united states so and he eventually gets
it
but he still has to check in every year
with united states authorities
and and say you know hey i'm here i'm
living here
you know you can find me here blah blah
blah and then and at any point
the attorney general of the united
states could decide
you know what we're done with norman
he's going back
so that's so he's still in a precarious
position but he did
obtain relief there are people who
obtain cat and stay the rest of their
lives
you know cat relief and stay the rest of
their lives in the united states so
it could happen with norman as well
that's terrifying not only do your
enemies hate you
but your old friends hate you and they
want to kill you as well
and then the people that are supposed to
protect you from both of those groups
they're also
they also hate you and they're going to
kill you it's um
yes it's crazy you talk about in some
gruesome detail the conditions of the
prisons and
the way that some of the experiences go
through can you tell us
some of the more extreme stories that
you heard about
the conditions in the prisons and what's
going on there
well i think it's important to consider
that when the gangs
basically what happens is more and more
gang members
who had begun their lives in the gang in
the united states
get deported back to places like el
salvador
in huge numbers and that's what
establishes the base for which
the gang emerges in el salvador are
these deportees
they then begin their operations or they
start doing
their activities many of them violent in
el salvador and they start to land in
jail
in el salvador and when they land in
jail in el salvador this is the late
1990s early 2000s
they are at the they are at the
disadvantage they they
are smaller in number than some of their
rivals
uh including the rival gang the 18th
street but also
the the most powerful uh criminal
prison gangs at the time and those
prison gangs
are brutal in many respects and perhaps
the most
brutal part of it is that they uh
commit horrible acts of sexual violence
against them
you know one of the first things that
norman sees
when he is ushered into i think it's the
third jail
um the mariona right as super famous
uh jail in in el salvador and the
biggest of all the jails in el salvador
run by
a brutal prison gang is is one
is another ms-13 member he gets uh so
normally gets ushered into a cell
and in this cell he is he's in front
of uh another member who's being raped
right in front of him
in this jail cell um that other member
ends up dying of of aids according to um
uh aids related illnesses according to
norman so this is
this is his this is his initiation into
the jail
of course this is something that is um
you know a another point of
of cohesion of of these particular
criminal organizations
especially inside jail is this risk of
sexual assault
um and so they are they are definitely
they almost immediately you know begin
to bind to
each other and they begin to form their
own very strong presence inside the
prison
enough so that they can confront this
stronger
prison gang which is doing not just you
know rapes inside of those prisons but
is extorting them
is extorting their family members is
assaulting their their family members
including uh um sometimes sexual assault
um you know is beating them openly you
know with the guard's
support because you know there are these
kind of informal packs
between guards and you know you know
strong prison gangs
you know in a lot of ways in a in a very
perverse way it kind of makes
the prison guard's job easier if there
is a you know one master yes exactly
self-enforcement so i think you probably
know all too well what i'm talking about
and so there is you know there's that
aspect that's playing out
um and you have the emergence of these
other
these other you know criminal prison
gangs one of them is the ms-13
to the point where um you know the
fighting
begins and then the fighting gets so bad
that the government makes a strategic
decision to begin to
separate them so the ms-13 goes to one
prison
or they actually control like two or
three prisons and then the 18th street
goes to another prison
which gives them de facto control total
control over those prisons
and basically gives them an operational
headquarters
in many respects so you can see the
logic behind it
you know it's an effort to slow the
violence but the
the the the sort of ripple effects
thereafter they didn't foresee
it's so you damned if you're doing
damned if you don't in that situation
they're committing crime out on the
streets they're killing each other if
they're in jail
and then if you do the only option which
is left to kind of segregate
jails based on gangs then you
essentially end up with a paid for
headquarters
and it seems like most of those jails
are
kind of fairly hands off for the guards
i saw ross kemp
um in an ms-13 run
jail pretty terrible conditions they're
talking about how all of their homies
have all got
diarrhea and stomach upsets and it's
really dirty and there's people hanging
from hammocks and like
20 people per cell 30 people per cell
it's absolutely packed
but at least they're safe from their
enemies right and the guards just kind
of
the guards take the take ross up to
basically the front gate
and then they're like right okay now
we're gonna hand you over to the guy
that runs this but the guy that runs
this isn't some commissioner from the
prison
it's the head inmate yes
that's exactly right i mean i i haven't
i have never been in an ms-13 controlled
jail
in el salvador but i went into an 18th
street one and it was the exact same
experience
they the guards um open the door
and then close the door behind you and
then that's the space you're in
yeah i mean you know i mean it's a
it is it is a strange strange feeling
and they're they're living
in in i mean horrible conditions i mean
yeah it's squalor
um you know one hammock above the other
and you know
sleeping over the the toilet and uh
yeah it's not not fun either so
no the prison the prison question is
um i think you know a sort of forgotten
element of this
and you know going back to the mexican
mafia even their
operational style in the us and and many
other
prison gangs that are operating in the
us
we just we just think that we can
you know lock them up and throw away the
key and we're done with it
and it's just so not the case
and i just don't know when when we're
going to come around to that realization
maybe
never what were the authorities in el
salvador trying to do to crack down on
this because
it's gonna just become a war in the
streets if you send the cops in i've
seen
videos i think it might have been ross
kemp or maybe a vice news documentary i
watched today about ms-13
where they use raids as an opportunity
that's almost like a pr
stunt to give this show of force
to anybody that's nearby in the
neighborhood so they'll send 250
special forces and armed soldiers in to
take down a
relatively small number of people but it
just seems like that's a mess and then
they would they were jailing people for
just having affiliation tattoos and
and clothing and colors of clothing at
one point it seems like a mess
yeah i mean a lot of the um legislation
around dealing with gangs
really emerged in california in the
1980s
when they were dealing with this
epicenter of gang activity in the united
states you know the place where
the ms-13 was born had about 400 gangs
operational
in that in that area and what they did
was they created special units of the
type that you're talking about
the most famous of which in los angeles
was called crash
which included the word hoodlum in it
in the acronym which is you know
something you wouldn't necessarily get
in a sort of special unit
these days so you had that and they
uh you know they would do very similar
style operations very much kick the door
down
you know flashy type of things and and
you know
sort of bring them all in jail but we
know what happened to them in jail they
became part of the surenos and part of a
larger network were deported back down
et cetera et cetera we know that part of
the story
but parallel to that they're also
creating databases
and those databases have all kinds of
problems uh associated with them
since they're um you know it's very much
a kind of the criteria upon which
you are included in those databases are
very flimsy to say the least um
there was a database the most famous
database which was one of the first in
california
an analysis of that in 2014 i believe
you know there were a couple of uh four
year olds
that were on the database um you know a
gang database
so you know it's that sort of thing and
then they create legislation
which allows them to enhance penalties
sentences
in the legislation has and this is
perhaps the original sin that you were
referring to earlier
a notion of gangs which they essentially
copy pasted from the united nations
definition of organized crime
but if you take my word for it they are
not organized crimes
unorganized crime if you are going to
like start
if if that's your premise upon which you
are building out legislation
then we're in trouble and not just that
but over the years
all of the states have developed their
own laws
regarding the gangs and they haven't
there's no
single definition of what a gang is
there are and we counted these when we
were doing a report at incite crime
there were 40 out of 50 states plus dc
they were you know plus the district of
columbia there were
44 different definitions of gang
plus dc's definition of gang so 45 out
of 51
of these jurisdictions had different
definitions
of what a gang was so where are we going
with all this
it eventually not only is it is it sort
of
replicated in mass in the united states
but we export that same model to places
like el salvador and what do they start
doing they start arresting them for the
same
flimsy style reasons they start creating
databases they
start over populating their jails
and lo and behold they have not just the
same problems
and many regards much worse problems and
why are we surprised i mean it just
for me it's kind of baffling how we turn
away from
what what the the story tells us what
the data tells us
you know what we can prove empirically
about what works
and maybe more importantly what
definitely does not work
so i mean this is this is kind of the
lesson that we see over and over again
and then we're surprised that this gang
has been around for 40 years
why are we surprised when we keep doing
the same thing as it relates to them
i'm not saying it's easy to wipe out any
gang but we can certainly mitigate
them with much more effective policies
that are much broader in scope
than simply thinking about it in a
punitive way
i put stephen dudley in charge i say
right you've got the resources at your
disposal
what do you do look i think
i think you can't i'm not gonna get rid
of the law enforcement component that's
already there that has its own inertia
who's gonna fight that battle
nobody right but you have you're already
you're already talking like a politician
you have to exactly exactly i've already
backtracked
exactly i've already like swallowed all
of what i just said
five minutes ago now the middle the
middle section of this
is what what do we do like you know now
for
the people who could be potential
potentially brought into these
organizations these communities i think
we need to work more
on you know creating alternative
communities
right we need to create competing
communities things that can compete
with the what the gang gives them and
that includes everything from thinking
about
how do we protect people to how do we
involve them
to how do we make sure that they're
crossing you know their interests with
other people's interests and
you know like-minded interests and maybe
that includes
nationality and ethnicity and race and
all that other stuff i think we need to
think about all these things
and when we create these alternative
spaces one of these alternative or de
facto alternative spaces
are the church and we need to study why
is
the questions that you were asking me
earlier why is why is the evangelical
church why is that even acceptable
to them that's a competing community you
know
and so that that's the type of thing i
think we need to think about
in this sort of medium term is how to
create these competing communities
and then in the very very long term we
need to think about how you deal with
violence um you know particularly
violence in the home
so we don't put near enough resources
towards early family
intervention and i'm talking about
dealing with you know families that have
a lot of situations of abuse you know
physical
and sexual abuse in particular so hyper
focus on that because
what we know about people who end up in
jail
is that a huge portion of them have been
were abused
in their home um so this is this is
something we need to consider
when we're considering you know
long-term how
are we changing the way people sort of
approach or interact with other human
beings
um so i think there's a lot of different
things a sort of immediate term is you
know
certainly we have to deal with the
problems that that gangs pose
and much of those problems are related
to law enforcement
we have to deal with the issues uh in
terms of
you know the way in which they've
created this very attractive and
obviously
you know anti-social but very much
attractive community
and we have to deal with the problems
you know the sort of
core root problems that happen inside
the home
you know that very often lead people to
to join those spaces
it's interesting i am
it's not an easy task sadly and this is
why
every time that i get exposed to work
like yours or
shaun atwood's uh true crime podcast
this big podcaster in the uk often has a
lot of guys from
ex-gang affiliations on there
whenever i listen to that i think god
like this is such a big behemoth
such a leviathan of a problem to try and
fix
and then when you hear politicians that
come on and
throw buzz words like tough on crime or
like
crack down on criminals you think
what does that even mean like it's so
long it's
it this isn't a task that even the
president that gets into office
next time is the next term he's going to
fix this is the thing that
aims to be fixed in 50 years or so um
what are your predictions moving forward
the future of el salvador obviously
we've seen this decline in
murder rate but that could be the uh the
the gang's basically fettling the
figures
what do you think we'll see over the
next decade or so from ms-13
i i i fear a little bit the next decade
um in in in in one respect
in that i do see the beginnings of kind
of an evolution
of of the ms-13 in a way that i hadn't
seen
this more sophisticated criminal
enterprise
they're becoming more sophisticated
leveling up they're
leveling up they're getting more
sophisticated they're
beginning to understand in a way they
hadn't shown before
on both a criminal level so their
understanding of how to deal with
excess resources put those resources to
work
you know get involved in other types of
economic activities so more legitimate
businesses
money laundering activities which shows
you sort of an
element of how much they're accumulating
as well
and also on a political level they're
understanding what their
where their leverage points are and
how to pull those levers i mean that's
that's what they're really getting
when they're interacting with these
governments is
they know when to pull these levers they
know how to they know how to
you know create the uh the uh effective
um communications channels and you know
send the messages that they want and get
what they want so anyway we're seeing
that
so i feared a little bit in that respect
on another level i say to myself you
know what
this is how criminals
become legitimate parts of society
no matter what country you know every
single
criminal group whether we're talking
about the you know irish mafia
or the italian mafia or any other sort
of criminal group is they become
sophisticated and they
over time pieces of them or their sort
of
generations below them become legitimate
you know and this is how it works
because there
are not these sort of traditional
avenues of of moving up the social
ladder
how else do we expect them to
you know become part of legitimate
society other than
criminal activities and it's not limited
to gangs but
i feel like the gang mostly
we're talking about el salvador he's
beginning to kind of
see that you know it's kind of it's kind
of crystallizing in front of them
in el salvador i wouldn't be surprised
if 10 years from now
we have a much different ms-13
just in el salvador you know um
you know i don't think maybe maybe parts
of honduras but
you know just in el salvador and if not
an ms-13
you know clicks i like to talk about uh
gangs within a gang the gang is so big
these clicks are so big some of these
clicks have thousands of members
themselves
and they're operational on an
international scale and because my
loyalty is very often with my clique
you know these clicks could evolve into
criminal organizations
in and of themselves much more
sophisticated so that is that's kind of
what i see
as a possibility but on the other hand i
say
maybe this is the process whereby they
become part of legitimate society
less violence certainly illicit proceeds
will
tilt the playing field in their favor on
the economic grounds on political
grounds
that's not fair but criminal groups do
this all the time
and they've done this all the time
throughout history so we should not be
surprised
if that's the path that they're
beginning to take
and maybe we shouldn't get in their way
i mean maybe
we'll hasten their arrival to legitimate
society will lower
the amount of carnage extortion
murders you know forced recruitment
rape everything else that is related to
you know the activities of this gang and
they are numerous
um numerous and so maybe
maybe if we hasten that that trip maybe
we might be better
off because we're certainly not doing
anything to slow down the other
you know 40 years same amount of
same numbers at least the same numbers
if not more
you know greater presence in more
countries now
what are we doing you know we're not
doing much to mitigate what they are
so we need to rethink this maybe i i
don't know i'm getting lost in my own
thoughts right now
man that's a tough pill to swallow that
permitting them to act more effectively
as criminals
is the most expedient way to get them
out of the worst types of criminality
that we want to get rid of
yeah it's um do you know what it is i i
actually think it's a
i'm not sure whether it's true and i'm
glad i'm not in the position to have to
make the call
but it there's part of me that does make
does make sense and it comes back to
what you said at the very beginning
about them being this sort of
hand-to-mouth organization
part of what makes them feel quite
jarring to
i think me when i think about it and
probably a lot of the listeners as well
is this level of poverty around them it
makes you think
kind of like the rwandan genocide they
even use machetes as well
right it's this sort of low-grade
low-rent unsophisticated
wanton violence and
i would imagine that when there aren't
these opportunities if you're if you've
got enough money for a car and a house
and a mansion and these sort of things
you're not bothered about running around
just
killing people over petty turf wars
because you have bigger things on your
mind
the i guess the inevitability of the
criminal enterprise is that there's a
lot of operations that need to be looked
after
that take time away from being on the
street doing stuff
i i wanted to ask you this this story as
well that i heard
last year i can't remember if it was in
brazil or venezuela
or or somewhere else
someone was trying to enact or someone
refused to enact
a 6pm curfew for covid
and the gang made a public statement and
said if the government won't act
we will and they enforced a covid
curfew and that story stuck with me
while i was reading the book
because it made me think oddly and you
hear these stories
about um i don't know whether it was el
chapo or another one of the the sort of
big mexican cartels
who would go and give money to people
they would fund
schools they'd have roads things named
after them i'm aware that there are
better saints to put on a pedestal
but my point is that you as the gangs
become more sophisticated they actually
integrate themselves into life in a more
productive way
yes sure they're still extorting people
and doing all of these bad things
but it really does feel like um you know
seth gordon's the dip
you know that kind of uh the area where
you have
real lack of capacity to do stuff it
feels like ms-13s in that
it feels like they haven't got the
resources to integrate and get
any of the good things look at me
talking about the good things of
criminal enterprises
i haven't got any of the advantages that
come with a sophisticated
criminal organization but they have all
of the aggression
and the members and the free time in the
world and the enemies
to have these territory wars
yeah i mean it's i guess kind of
how do we how do we change the equation
and
and who are we changing the equation for
you know
i think there are a lot of different
when we talk about the gang
uh we think about sort of one
one sort of narrow strip of of
population but
you know really you know we're talking
about like
kids from you know kids i say young
adults
18 to 25 right that's your that's your
gang strip
right there so that's your kind of
target but maybe that's not the right
target you know i mean
i i don't know it's it's so hard to say
where
you know where to put the the emphasis
but i think in in your
in your description of it what i think
about is how do we change the
the calculation and if you can change
the calculation from
it's in my interest to send four guys
out with machetes
after this guy and it won't even it
doesn't even mean that i'm going to
you know win uh that drug corner it has
nothing to do with that it's just
because he's the other side of he's the
other gang
if i can change start by changing that
equation that it's not in my interest to
do that
then we're moving in the right direction
um you know and
of course that is like the lowest bar i
mean
you know stop chopping people up stop
chopping people up that's the first
thing we wanted to have to happen
exactly stop
making that be your a rewarding
experience
you know why is that why is that a
rewarding experience you know and part
of that of course you know going back
that
part of that is a law enforcement
equation but part of that is sort of
shifting the direction of where where
they could be putting their energies
it's a it's an incredibly difficult
question
to to answer in the in the hole
right but but i think that there's
there's so many resources that are
already in place
that can answer it on the micro level
that i think a lot of it is just trying
to sort of figure out where to harness
the existing
resources that are already at play i
don't think we need any
extra resources in that regard
you know i don't know it's a you know
we're trying to we're trying to solve
the gang problem here
in a in an hour-long podcast it's a
tough one rightly so if there are two
men on this planet to do it stephen it's
me and you
and stephen dudley ladies and gentlemen
people want to check out more of your
stuff
where should they go you can go to
stephendudly.com
or you can go to insightcrime.org that's
the
organization that i co-direct
and we cover organized crime in the
americas
so have a look thank you very much man i
appreciate your time ms-13 the making of
america's most notorious gang will be
linked in the show notes below as well
cheers man thank you very much chris for
having me thank you very much for tuning
in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace
you